it is election day 2022 and as is often
the case on election days in the United
States everyone has their take everyone
has their view Everyone likes to say
this is the one thing that this is
really all about it's really you know it
in times past it's really a referendum
on Trump or this is really about a
corporations versus individuals or
whatever and almost always there really
is no one thing and so I've resisted
that type of language but this time
there really kind of is the one big
thing the one big thing at stake here
today is are we going to make a move in
the direction of being for democracy
where the candidate that gets the most
votes wins and assumes office without
controversy or are we going to make
another move away from democracy where
even if you don't get the most votes
people claim you should still assume the
office you ran for and they may even be
able to make it a reality
if we aren't careful and if we don't
make the correct votes today that is
fundamentally what today's election is
about imagine 20 50 100 years from now
and think about today as an inflection
point one story that could be told is
well Trump came to power in 2016. he was
defeated in 2020 after a very dangerous
four years of insanity and then the Maga
movement moved in in 2022 took over the
Senate and or house a bunch of the
governor's houses then as a result of
that was able to steal an election in
2024 leading to the end of American
democracy as we knew it in 2028 and on
downhill from there right that's one
story
that if we think about today as an
inflection point could be told 20 50 100
years from now
there's a different story which could be
told again because it's an inflection
point it could be Trump did come to
power in 2016 and then was defeated in
2020 after that very same dangerous four
years of insanity but then in 2022 a
little bit of Sanity returned there's
still tens of millions of lunatics and
we see them all the time but a little
bit just enough sanity returned
that the tens of millions of
anti-democracy lunatics were defeated on
November 8 2022 absolute disaster was
just barely averted and then things got
on to a more logical path in 26 and in
24 26 28 Etc
it's a Divergence point it's an
inflection point and those are two
possible stories that could be told
consider these contrasts uh Rolling
Stones uh azawin sub-sang and Patrick
rice are reporting that quote Trump is
calling Republicans to ask how many
times they will impeach Biden if they
win tonight think of that now on the
other hand Joe Biden and Barack Obama
have been touring the country saying we
need to save democracy this is not
fundamentally about should the top tax
rate on the richest Americans be 35 37
or 39 percent
that's a question it's a perfectly
reasonable question and at times past we
talked a lot about questions like that
we're dealing with something very
different here okay now by the way in
the meantime Joe Biden is predicting
that Democrats win
on the basis of an improving economy
that's also possible we just don't know
based on the polling right now the
posters really don't know and we're
going to talk about that next but before
we do that I really hope every single
one of you that votes in the United
States has already voted or is planning
to vote and I keep getting this in my
email David I care about what's
happening but one vote never makes a
difference these elections never come
down to one vote so it's really hard to
feel like my vote actually matters and
I've been talking about this on our
streams lately I understand that feeling
I think the same thing when when has a
gubernatorial race or a senate race come
down to a single vote therefore my vote
doesn't matter wrong the way you have to
think about it is as follows tons of
people have that thought tons of people
consider staying home because it never
comes down to one vote and they all say
my vote isn't going to make the
difference here think about that as a
group you're a part of
and once you think about it that way
elections often come down to do the
people who wonder is my vote going to
make a difference does that constituency
does that group stay home or vote we all
have that thought
if every one of us who thought it never
comes down to a one vote I'll stay home
if we all do stay home we lose a bunch
of Elections that we could win okay so
don't fall for my vote doesn't make a
difference that's another way that these
right Wingers like to suppress the vote
don't let them do it we'll have results
live tonight on YouTube twitch and
Facebook starting at 7 30 Eastern
4 30 on the west coast all right
um the pollsters really don't know
what's going to happen tonight
and I have been a defender of polling to
the extent that we understand the
methodology being used you might
remember that the Wright loves to say
the pollsters got it really wrong in
2016. they really didn't the national
popular vote polls said it would be a
three-point margin by which Hillary
would win and Hillary won by a little
over two points in the National popular
vote the polling was correct but it did
not correctly get the electoral vote
because that came down to very small
margins in a few States so the the the
the general overarching attacks on
polling I'm not big on them they're not
super interesting to me but it is true
that in these particular midterms the
polls may not reflect what's going to
happen tonight there's a very good Daily
Beast article called pollsters have no
effing idea what's going to happen this
election and it says pollsters and
election handicappers are very worried
they could be wrong in decisive ways for
the 2022 midterms now this is a this is
a a the this is a result of two big
things number one
the margins particularly in the Senate
are expected to be very small so when
your most likely outcome is one party
has 51 seats or the other party has 51
seats that's already a range that only
comes down to a couple of seats many of
these races are super close Oz fetterman
is a tie
Walker Warnock is a tie
that's your Senate right there that's
your you know all else being equal those
two races that are ties determine who
controls the Senate so because it's very
close even a small margin of error can
be one party controls the senate or
another party controls the Senate the
other thing that's going on is that
there are growing issues and you can
read the article we'll link to it there
are growing issues with the polling in
two particular ways a lot of the
aggregators like real clear politics are
using a lot of overtly right-wing
pollsters in their uh calculations so
just for example like if you look at
Walker Warnock you see that Trafalgar is
being included in the average Trafalgar
is a known right-leaning pollster so is
that throwing off the numbers that's one
thing and then number two to some degree
you know a lot of people don't pick up
calls from unknown numbers at all
anymore and there is starting to be
aside from the stuff that's done online
for the phone stuff they're starting to
potentially be a sort of self-selection
bias and the people that are interested
in getting on the phone and talking to a
pollster and it can include people who
want to sway the polls in a particular
way okay so the point here is it's
election day ignore the polls but also
the polls really may not be telling us
what's going to happen tonight now
here's the danger of this right-wing
skew to the polls if indeed there is one
you know we're going to look at Clips
later
the the right is telling us they're
going to claim fraud
they're going to do it it's they're
going to claim fraud and one of the ways
they may claim that fraud is by saying
did you see the polls leading up to the
election
you expect us to believe that despite
the polls all these Democrats won now
these are the very same people who in
elections past say you can't trust the
polls but they are going to weaponize
this right-wing push-polling to say look
at the polls and look at what you tell
us was the actual vote that's not
believable it must have been rigged
that's the danger we will have results
in a few hours and then we can put the
polling question aside Republicans are
already suing to throw out mail-in
ballots
okay today is election day 2022.
Republicans aren't even waiting they're
already suing to get thousands of
mail-in ballots thrown out there's a
good Washington Post piece about this
Republicans Sue to disqualify thousands
of mail-in ballots and swing States the
lawsuits coincide with a systemic effort
by Republican leaders to persuade voters
to cast ballots in person and not
absentee
um
critics are calling it a concerted
attempt at partisan voter suppression of
course it is
in Pennsylvania we've talked about this
before the state supreme court has
agreed with the RNC
election officials should not count
ballots on which the voter neglected to
write a date on the outer envelope even
if the ballots arrive before election
day thousands of ballots have been set
aside as a result enough to swing a
close race that could be your race right
there
in Michigan Christina caramo the
Republican nominee for Secretary of
State sued the top election official in
Detroit last month seeking to toss
absentee ballots not cast in person with
an ID even though that runs contrary to
State requirements understand that's not
what the requirements say must be done
when asked in a court hearing caramo's
lawyer declined to say why the suit is
only targeting the city of Detroit a
heavily Democratic majority black City
and not the entire State I wonder why
I wonder why and in Wisconsin
Republicans won a Court ruling that will
prevent some mail-in ballots from being
counted when the required witness
address is not complete look at some of
the things they've done this election
cycle alone continued gerrymandering
based on the 2020 census of course
that's the default some of it has been
has been blocked some of it has
succeeded eliminate polling places in
minority neighborhoods to create long
lines so disproportionately Democratic
voters might say the line's too long I
gotta go because I have a life I have a
job I have kids I have errands okay make
it illegal to give people water when
they are waiting in line again dissuade
them from sticking around to vote but
only do only and try to have it enforced
in certain areas Sue to stop mail-in
voting altogether Sue to have mail-in
ballots thrown out as they are doing
here and then of course as we saw in
Arizona have armed poll Watchers at
polling places to intimidate but only
certain polling place
okay
it's not happening you know for all of
the conspiracy theories about secret
cabals and subterfuge that we're not
aware you know all these different
things
it's all happening in the open it's all
happening in the open and so I hope that
you were able to vote without incident
after the break we're going to talk
about a trump lawyer admitting oh we're
going to claim fraud as soon as there's
any delay in getting results which there
will be because of how the state laws
are set up but I hope you were able to
vote if you weren't if you had problems
email info davidpackman.com
and we will um highlight some of those
stories if there are any hopefully there
aren't but if there are any we will
highlight some of those stories on
tonight's results stream make sure that
you are subscribed on YouTube and that
you are following on Twitch or Facebook
those are the three platforms where we
will be streaming tonight starting at 7
30 Eastern
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
the David pakman Show podcast YouTube
Channel radio show TV show and live
streaming all is primarily funded by
people in the audience you go to
joinpakman.com you get a membership it's
quick it's easy and it's great oh the
bonus show where you want to make
a mangoes is bad we do a daily bonus
show Alex Jones who sells you know other
things is furious about the fact that
what we offer is just extra content
that's not a joke that's not an Alex
Jones impersonator that's really Alex
Jones Furious about the bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show get the
commercial free audio and video feeds
every day get the invitations to the
members only live town halls with me
and anger Alex Jones by virtue of
supporting Progressive Independent Media
at joinpakman.com today is the last day
for the coupon code big voting 22. today
is the last day you don't need to go far
or speculate
to know or predict what the Maga right
is going to do tonight and tomorrow and
over the next few days when it comes to
the election results they are going to
claim fraud
how do we know this because they're
telling us much like we figured out in
the summer of 2020 that the Trump
campaign was going to be claiming fraud
over mail-in ballots and other things in
the 2020 election
they're telling us they're going to do
it here is Trump lawyer Christina Bob
who also is an anchor on the right-wing
channel right side broadcasting this is
last night in Vandalia Ohio and she says
if any results are delayed Beyond early
in the morning tomorrow morning they are
going to claim fraud listen to this we
do have a better chance than knowing who
won and who lost an election I think so
I expect to know who won by like the
middle of the night maybe very very
early Wednesday morning if we don't and
if Democrats try to extend the vote I
think they're going to have a very very
hard time doing it with any level of
credibility all right now did you see
what she just did there
she did she slipped something in that's
totally incoherent she says if we don't
have the results early tomorrow morning
and Democrats try to extend the vote no
one is this is no one's extending the
vote okay extending the vote is allowing
more time for people to vote
it's that's not even at issue here okay
she's already mixing two different
things and they love to do this
one thing is just allowing people to
continue to the rules are clear
um you have to get your absentee ballots
in
if you're in line at the time that polls
close you're allowed to vote and beyond
that that's it separately there's the
issue of how quickly your votes counted
and we'll get back to that in a moment
in 2020 they were able to do it because
they claimed covid and they had this
excuse which we all know was baloney
because they had to go find more ballots
and do all of their ballot harvesting
none of that happened that's that's just
a lie there's no evidence for that
whatsoever
but I think that's going to be really
hard to do tomorrow because everybody
knows like you should be able there's no
reason you can't have a tally and for a
state let's say there's four million
voters in Michigan or Ohio and they get
through three and a half million by
midnight you're telling me you can't get
through another half a million in a
couple hours I mean it's a no-brainer
yeah now what she doesn't mention is
that the reason that in a lot of the
states they stop counting at a certain
time or it takes a long time is because
of rules that Republican legislatures
and secretaries of State have put in
place many states as a result of laws
enabled by Republican legislatures
aren't allowed to even start counting
mail-in ballots until after the poll is
close you could have the mail-in ballots
counted as they come in or at designated
times you could say okay on November 7th
we'll count everything that's come in
and we'll get a very good jump start on
getting those final numbers Republican
legislatures in many cases say we don't
touch we don't count anything until the
polls close in other states the
legislatures decide you stop counting at
a certain time 10 11 p.m midnight and
you don't start until the next day no
matter how close you are so Christina
Bob now wants to make it make it seem
it's very suspicious I mean listen if
you're almost done counting at midnight
just keep counting they pass laws saying
that you can't do that and it is almost
certain that I listen
we we have to know what to expect if
Pennsylvania is close and it may be very
Shapiro is going to easily defeat
mastriano but Oz Spider-Man could be
very close we could be talking about
hundreds or thousands of votes making
the difference
when they stop counting
we're not going to know
and there's not going to be anything
inherently suspicious about that these
are the rules that the state legislature
put in place so they are telling us what
they're planning to do
they are going to use this to try to
steal some races as they did in 2020 and
we have to be prepared there's two
things
from a legal standpoint Democrats have
to be prepared to prevent Shenanigans
but from an emotional standpoint we all
have to be ready not to react when they
go oh it's so suspicious they brought in
ham sandwiches at 11 30 it was the wrong
number of sandwiches and there were two
Orthodox Jews and they still brought ham
and that's very suspicious it's probably
because fetterman stole it right we have
to remember these these people they're
nuts okay and not to get fired up we
know what the processes are in States
like this we went through the
Pennsylvania thing two years ago and not
to allow them to rile us up
but they're going to try they're going
to claim fraud Carrie Lake will claim
fraud in Arizona she'll just claim
victory if we don't know the results uh
if she doesn't win they're going to do
it they're telling us that they're going
to do it I'm going to play for you
something horribly irresponsible Fox
News Dr Mark Siegel went on Tucker
Carlson's show last night and in a sort
of final Salvo to try to hurt John
fetterman said John fetterman is either
going to have another stroke while in
office or even will die in office he
says he said statistically he's not
going to survive a six-year term as
Senator as many of you may know Oz
versus fetterman Pennsylvania Senate
race John fetterman suffered a stroke
some months ago everything that we have
seen from his doctors and everything we
can glean from when we see fetterman
writing for example it's abundantly
clear that he is cognitively fine
however the stroke has left them with a
deficit in terms of auditory processing
converting things that he hears
into meaningful messages instantly the
way we all do and turning what he wants
to say into a coherent speech he
sometimes struggles with that and Mark
Siegel went on and said this this guy's
not even going to survive a term and
I'll tell you in a moment where where
the information is coming from and of
course remember that Mark Siegel is not
fetterman's doctor he is not well
positioned to really comment on this and
setterman himself has said that his
stroke was due to a blood clot from the
heart that is very significant Tucker
because a study out of a journal called
stroke very prominent Journal looking at
over 6 000 people from Great Britain
have found that if your blood clot comes
from the heart you have about less than
a 60 percent a sixty percent chance more
than a sixty percent chance of either
not living five years or having another
stroke within those five years it's
greater than sixty percent chance so I
say to the voters of Pennsylvania
tonight who are ready to check a box
tomorrow yeah he's he's a doctor but
he's telling voters how to vote okay I
think before you check a box you should
consider a statistic like that greater
than 60 chance that someone like
fetterman with a heart in his condition
having had a stroke will either have a
recurrence or won't survive the term
okay so sucker
it's like why not just I mean this
happened in may they had time to put a
real candidate in it okay so let's go
through this first of all imagine if CNN
did a segment like this
about any Republican just just just
imagine what would be happening if they
did that that's number one secondly
where did the doctor get this
information I don't know he talks about
a British study
I was not able to find that study the
study I was able to find on stroke
survival rates is from Denmark and it
did not include 6 000 people it included
5 000 people and it included 5 000
people who suffered Strokes between 1982
and 1991. so first and foremost it's a
period that started 40 years ago and
ended 30 years ago so right away we
should be saying okay has stroke
treatment and Recovery improved in the
last 30 to 40 years and the answer is
absolutely so if again we we don't know
what study he's talking about this is
the study I found
indeed that study does say your risk of
death increases to 60 percent
in the five years following certain
types of Strokes for this group who
suffered Strokes between 1982 and 1991.
now the problem with assessing fetterman
in this way is that the mortality is
overwhelmingly skewed to people in their
80s followed by people in their 70s
followed by people in their 60s okay so
fetterman's 53. so right away you've got
to take that 60 percent and say this was
based on treatment 30 to 40 years ago
the mortality is heavily skewed to the
80 70 and 60 year olds okay
but what's the most important thing here
the most important thing is that this is
a very dangerous road to go down if you
want to just play statistical games let
me explain Chuck Grassley senator from
Iowa up for re-election he's 89 years
old
How likely is it remember folks we're
we're just looking at the numbers facts
don't care about your feelings
statistically
89 year old men once you make it to 89
years old as a man in the United States
you're likely to live four more years
and the Senate term is six years
statistically you can say what Siegel is
saying about fetterman about Grassley
grassly why is anyone how is this guy
they should have put a real candidate up
grassly statistically won't survive a
term he will die in office if we elect
him why is no one talking about that
the reality is these people know there's
no rational reason not to vote for
fetterman there just isn't Oz isn't even
really from Pennsylvania he's a [ __ ]
he's a quack TV Doctor he's a
flip-flopper but not because his views
have genuinely changed for good factual
reasons it's because he's putting his
finger to the political wins so they go
after fetterman's character and they go
after fetterman's Health in a way where
listen if we want to play an Actuarial
game there's a hell of a lot of
Republicans who you should not be
electing because statistically they are
not likely to survive a six-year Senate
term these people are pathetic and just
imagine for a second imagine for a
second how they would be reacting
if CNN did this about a republican
candidate uh we'll have this clip and
other clips from today's show on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show you can also find my personal
Instagram there by searching for
david.pakman
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to have back on the program today Andrew
Seidel who's a civil rights and
constitutional attorney with Americans
United for separation of church and
state his new book is American Crusade
how the Supreme Court is weaponizing
religious freedom Andrew really great to
have you back on today
oh it's a pleasure to be back thank you
so much for having me so you know we
knew we predicted it was sort of written
on the wall that uh after the 2015
Supreme Court decision that said you can
no longer ban gay marriage at the state
level
um it wasn't that uh the idea of
weaponizing homophobia uh in the law was
going to go away it was simply going to
move to sort of other venues one of them
was going to be
um attempts at employer discrimination
on the basis of religious freedom and
and sort of using religious freedom the
baker case as many have talked about the
cake baker Etc can you talk a little bit
about how the Supreme Court which is now
one of the most conservative Supreme
Courts we've had in a while has assisted
in doing exactly this
oh absolutely I mean religious freedom
has long been a shield right it's
defended the minority against the
tyranny of the majority it's it's
defended us all against government
overreach and and never in our history
has it been a license to violate the
rights of other people or or to infringe
their rights in any way but this packed
Supreme Court
collaborating with a network of
well-funded powerful Christian
nationalist organizations is changing
that and these Crusaders I mean they are
weaponizing religious freedom and we've
seen it for the last decade in case
after case they are literally reshaping
the legal meaning of the First Amendment
and they're turning that protection into
a weapon that conservative Christians
can use to injure other people to
violate their rights and to impose their
religion on us all and so American
Crusade the new book tells the true
stories behind those Blockbuster cases
that are actually rewriting our
Constitution and it does so without the
the legalese and jargon that we lawyers
like to hide behind because I really
wanted everybody to be able to
understand the threat and see just how
radical and dangerous these Crusaders
and this these Supreme Court opinions
truly are and explaining these without
legalese is often so important just for
getting the average person to understand
what's kind of fundamentally at issue so
let's talk about the so-called gay
wedding cake case which is masterpiece
cake shop V the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission ultimately in in layperson's
terms why did the Court rule in favor of
the baker who did not want to bake the
cake
essentially the court manufactured
hostility against the bakery's religion
what it what the court said was that the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission which
is in charge of enforcing the state
civil rights law yes basically it was
mean and said mean things about the
baker's religion and that tainted the
whole process and effectively what it
did was it gave the baker get out of
jail free card now it didn't decide the
central issue does religious freedom
equal a license to discriminate and a
big part of that is because Charlie and
David the couple involved in this case
really did a great job of speaking out
about putting a face on this
discrimination and it made it difficult
I think for the court to make that
decision I also I will say that the
court is considering a case right now
303 creative versus Atlantis out of
Colorado
that is going to decide that issue at
least on the First Amendment Free Speech
grounds
um probably this term and there is no
couple that's been discriminated against
I think I think the Court's going to
finally do what it was not able to do
back in 2018. what do you make of the
cases that have to do with crosses and
you know Ten Commandments uh plaques and
and sorts of things on public lands and
or at government buildings like is is
there ever a time when that is
acceptable even though it appears to be
an establishment of one particular
religion over others and over
non-religion by the government and what
does the Supreme Court said about that
I mean historically the Supreme Court's
actually been pretty good about for the
most part striking down these overt
religious Expressions uh except that
we've seen that change in the last few
years
um especially uh with the Bladensburg
cross case that we saw now I mean one of
the things that was really striking to
me in writing this is I first of all
I've been in the trenches fighting these
cases for a decade I mean this is this
is my career I've I've litigated these
cases I've briefed them I've been in
front of Courts arguing these cases and
the the thing that I think a lot of
people don't understand it's partly
because this is part of the Crusade is
that these questions are actually really
simple to answer for the most part like
when religion and the law Collide the
answers the to the questions raised are
not that difficult for us to figure out
and I draw three simple lines in the
book you know synthesizing basically 200
plus years of precedent and the third
line is the separation of church and
state and it's pretty simple our
government has no religion to to
exercise you know so putting up a cross
on government property it is
inappropriate
um our and I think a lot of times we
fail we we talk about the separation of
church and state in vague terms and not
in terms that actually impact people in
their everyday lives right
um and it really is at its most basic
level in abuse of power when that line
is violated you have a public official
abusing state power
to impose their personal religion on
other people and that's a big problem
that's what for instance what we saw in
the case of the praying football coach
this past term at the court right this
is a state actor abusing his power to
impose his personal religion on other
people's kids and you have the Supreme
Court rubber stamping it and saying yep
we're cool with that yeah we've been
covering that since the beginning so if
I recall that the most recent news on
that is uh that the prayer was okay uh
at the at the center at the 50-yard line
um it was not a sort of coercive despite
the fact that this was the coach in a
position of power and authority and that
it's totally obvious that football
players high school kids might
reasonably feel that if they don't
participate maybe playing time is
jeopardized that they are they are in a
position of subservience for lack of a
better term there and apparently the
decision is that it was actually okay
and the coach is going to be reinstated
if I recall correctly
you do and there are a couple things to
to hit on it so first of all this is one
of the cases that I cover in the book
and I actually have an update on my
website going over all of the newest
materials yeah that's been coming out
and in that case we know for a fact that
students felt pressured right there's
there's no question students felt
pressured by their coach they felt that
they had to pray to play and you
actually had the Crusader involved in
this case first Liberty Institute which
is the the Christian nationalist
organization that brought the case all
the way to the Supreme Court yes you you
have them spinning what one of the lower
judges called a quote deceitful
narrative
right and that they're making up this
this idea of oh he's just saying a
private personal prayer
on the 50-yard line surrounded by
students surrounded by staff I mean it's
ridiculous to the point where in her
descent Justice Sonia Sotomayor is
including photographs to show that this
is a deceitful narrative
um in the lower courts one of the judges
actually puts the claims that first
Liberty Institute makes in his chart
beside what actually happened in reality
but the crazy thing about it and which
to me highlights the fact that our court
is packed and gone and is complicit in
this Crusade is that first Liberty
Institute instead of running and hiding
and burying their head in the sand after
a judge said they were spinning a
deceitful narrative they appealed to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
adopted the ultra-conservative block on
the Supreme Court rather adopted that
deceitful narrative wholesale
they just lied to us all when you look
at the current Supreme Court I know that
it can be hard to say this overall but
maybe specifically as it applies to the
areas that you're talking about here is
this the most right-wing Supreme Court
that there has been in I mean how long
I mean certainly Our Generation for sure
I mean this is one of the things though
that I think we really need to do and
this is what I try to do in American
Crusaders we have to unshackle our minds
from the belief that the Supreme Court
is an impartial Arbiter of Truth and
justice The Crusade depends upon people
believing this myth but look Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump and Leonard
Leo they cheated and stole and packed
the courts to put their collaborators in
place not because those collaborators
would administer justice even-handedly
but because they wouldn't specifically
because they wouldn't yeah exactly I
mean if they if they just wanted Justice
administered even-handedly Merrick
garland would have gotten a hearing
instead they spent 540 million dollars
packing the court with people they knew
would decide cases in in their way but
to answer your question I think what
we're actually seeing is a very
conservative regressive institution
returning to its mean I mean this is one
of the things that came across when I
was researching the book like the
Supreme Court historically is a very
conservative body we think of it as the
war in court we think of it as the court
that gave us Brown versus Board of
Education in Miranda versus Arizona and
Gideon versus Wainwright which says that
you have a right to counsel when you are
accused of a crime but but that's that's
kind of of the outlier in our Court's
history this is the court of Plessy
versus Ferguson and separate is equal of
of Dred Scott and fugitive slave laws of
trying to suffocate the New Deal in the
Cradle after it was one with the blood
of so many Americans during the Civil
War of Japanese internment camps of
Muslim bans of billionaires and
corporations and political
gerrymandering and vote suppression and
now of abolishing abortion and
reproductive freedom in the name of
their narrow religious beliefs so this
is the most conservative Court in our
lifetimes but certainly not in the
lifetime of this country last thing I
wanted to ask you about there were so
many cases particularly early during the
covid pandemic related to restrictions
on public Gatherings and also in some
cases related to masks and other things
and individuals would start to assert
religious Arguments for example that the
Gathering was really a religious
gathering due to opposition based on
religion to some of the guidelines that
were put in place or religious claims
related to masks or vaccines or whatever
the case may be can you talk a little
bit about that in the context of these
other things that we're talking about
and is it similar is it bogus how does a
court uh how does the current Court
think about such claims in that context
so this is actually one of one of the
chapters that I spend a lot of time on
because it really does crystallize and
highlight exactly the problem with this
Crusade and how fallacious it is at its
most basic level yeah um so I I go
through all the covet cases the big
coveted cases that hit the Supreme Court
both before and after Amy Coney Barrett
which is kind of the Tipping Point and
one of the things that became really
clear is that it's all kind of nonsense
if if you look at the other first
amendment claims that are made Free
Speech claims free assembly claims all
of those cases failed all of those cases
failed the only cases that one were
religious freedom claims and they only
won before Trump judges and Republican
appointed judges uh like 80 percent of
the time they won before Trump judges 50
of the time before Republican judges and
never before a Democrat appointed judge
which is the right call by the way and
is is what our precedence says I mean
there's very clear precedent going back
a hundred years saying that your
religious freedom him does not include a
right to risk the health and safety of
every other citizen in this country
especially during a pandemic I mean this
is a very clear line right this is what
I'm talking about with the weaponizing
of religious freedom they are turning
that protection into a weapon to harm
and impose on others and violate their
rights and nothing could be more clear
than that than saying during a pandemic
you can risk everybody else's lives
uh the book is excellent it's called
American Crusade how the Supreme Court
is weaponizing religious freedom there
are signed copies available using the
link that we'll put in the video
description on YouTube we have been
speaking with the book's author Andrew
Seidel who is a civil rights and
constitutional attorney Andrew always
great having you on I appreciate it
thank you so much always pleasure my
friend
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Donald Trump held his final unhinged
extreme lunatic rally in front of a
crowd of sycophants last night in
Vandalia Ohio and there were rumors that
he was going to announce his 2024
candidacy Trump did make an announcement
of a further announcement and a lot of
people highly titillated by this take a
look at Trump's big announcement
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida Florida
Okay so
by all reasonable assessments next
Tuesday Trump will be announcing that he
is running for the Republican
Presidential nomination in 2024. this
was a particularly disgusting rally the
energy was extra dangerous one of the
targets of trump in the last few days
has been Nancy Pelosi
and
um it is uh quite horrifying we will get
to that momentarily uh Donald Trump
insisting you know maybe he should be
given back the nuclear codes then it
sucks
nothing happened to him except a great
verdict he's got a great verdict we go
by that verdict the Sox verdict but no
he had it in his socks you know that
right and others took many many
documents they take him out of the White
House they took document I'm the only
one that can't take anything
but maybe our country would be better
off if I actually had the nuclear codes
JD because our enemies would be afraid
unlike the way they are now if I had to
think about what he's saying he's saying
I am so unstable that I actually might
just on a whim nuke people that me
having the codes would be a good
deterrent
don't forget he lost the nuclear codes
twice
how do you explain that to the military
I've lost the military codes what do you
he lost the military codes twice I
didn't
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you yeah
um completely unhinged I mean this this
is a man at this point so disconnected
from reality and Sanity that it is hard
to believe Trump then going after Nancy
Pelosi of course Nancy Pelosi's husband
recently attacked by a right-wing nut in
their home
he had to have skull surgery and here's
Trump talking about her she Pelosi said
please them animals they're human beings
I said no they're animals
of course I think she's an animal too
you want to know the kids what
they'll say oh what a horrible thing he
said about dancing she impeached me
twice for nothing
they'll say oh these people are fakers
back there they'll say what a horrible
thing he called Nancy Pelosi an animal
let me tell you what she does to this
country and what she did to the and the
turmoil and it was all I used the word
yesterday I shouldn't my great first
lady got very upset I said I will never
use the word [ __ ] again
but what she did to us in this country
and yet we got more done as an
Administration and a president than just
about any president in the history of
our country in four years
so continue to tax on Nancy Pelosi
extremely uh poor taste classless as
I've said before money cannot buy you
class now interestingly former Ted Cruz
staffer Amanda Carpenter tweeted last
night quote I haven't seen a trump
speech in a while but the way he spoke
last night so favorably of executing
drug dealers after a short two-hour or
less trial and then sending the bullet
they were shot with to their families
was jarring well what Amanda Carpenter
doesn't know
is that this has actually been part of
Trump's routine at every rally for the
last several months and Kevin McCarthy
was even asked about this on CNN he's
like no no we we kind of should be
changing the law to execute drug dealers
this is a sick and disgusting group of
people here's the clip that Amanda
Carpenter is referring to and again if
you haven't been paying attention to
these rallies you probably would be
horrified by this but Trump does this at
every rally and the crowd cheers the
world is horrified but the crowd cheers
I'm calling for the death penalty for
drug dealers and human traffickers which
will upon its passage reduce drug
distribution and reduce crime in our
country by a minimum of 75 percent on
the first day that this policy is
instituted and maybe I could ask JD to
lead it you will never lose an election
again if you did and I don't like to
bring this up it's a tough subject
nobody I don't know if the country is
ready for it I can tell you with
President XI in China I see him say
president you have one point five
billion people do you have a drug
problem no no listen to this problem
listen how do you do that I really sort
of knew but I didn't want to how do you
do that
and then he probably thought I was
somewhat naive he goes we have quick
trial I said what's a quick try I think
I knew what that was too that means they
catch a drug dealer they give them a
quick trial not a trial that takes
12 years
and 12 years of appeals 25 years later
and everyone's dead by the time they get
to the end of the no this is a trial
that takes approximately two hours this
is extraordinarily Authority
authoritarian this this is you know
Russia has a 99 conviction rate red flag
authoritarian nightmare
and if they're
executed and
the and the bullet and you know the
bullet I don't know if anybody wants to
know this it gets a little bit too
graphic but the bullet is said to their
families you know that right
do you know that it's actually sent to
their families it's pretty tough stuff
there's no games so they have no drug
problem whatsoever he actually thought
it was a foolish question I said do you
have a drug problem absolutely not what
are you talking about of course now
let's insert a little bit of Sanity into
what is a completely insane situation
during this rant Trump always claims
every drug dealer
kills 500 Americans each drug dealer is
responsible directly for killing 500
Americans
that's just made up
um
I mean just just Google it look for the
information check out anything you want
to check there is no evidence he's
grappled onto that fact that is not a
fact that claim and it is based in
nothing that's number one now number two
even for Trump's all of tough all of
Trump's tough talk about execute drug
dealers do a two-hour trial send the
bullet to their families even despite
all of that
Trump pardoned many drug dealers when he
was in office so even his own supposed
disdain and uh desperation for harsher
treatment of drug dealers Trump pardoned
many drug dealers when he was in office
so just another instance of hypocrisy
for sure uh last thing here and we're
not doing a ton of these clips today
we've got a lot of little things
Trump has started to refer to Trump
rallies as religious experiences and in
fact referred to the moment when it
started pouring at his Miami rally on
Sunday as such a religious experience
but you know the people it was actually
people have said today it was like a
religious experience the people the
music comes on and then boom we just got
it was like unbelievable I've never seen
anything like it right you know the
teleprompters one of them just crashed
and broke now remember
for years he criticized Barack Obama for
using a teleprompter and now Trump is
talking about forget about the fact that
he uses a teleprompter at every speech
he's talking about the fact that without
it it was really difficult to continue
giving a speech the other one was
useless because if you ever ride in your
car where you get a really heavy
rainstorm and try and see through
without the windshield wipers which by
the way
they planned it's called planned
obsolescence they can make a windshield
wiper that would last 100 years but they
make them only so they last exactly one
year then you have to buy a new one
which means they're smart Okay Trump
probably doesn't realize you just take a
paper towel to the windshield wiper and
then you know you get another year out
of it every time you do it but anyway
this is that's too pedestrian for Trump
let's let them keep them but you ever do
that where you're driving and you can't
see well that's what I had with my one
little remaining teleprompter so we had
to go and we had a great evening uh one
of the greatest rallies we've ever had
and it was caused by God sending us the
heaviest rain I've ever seen you know
what's funny about that and then we'll
move on some of you might remember when
Trump was inaugurated in January of 2017
he claimed that the rain stopped and the
sun came out and it was a sign from God
about how happy God was about Trump
being president now it was a lie it was
just rainy that day but most importantly
the point was God expresses his pleasure
by making it sunny
and now Trump is saying God expressed
his pleasure by sending rain to make it
like a religious experience that is
emblematic of right-wing thinking when a
happens it's because things are really
good
but when the opposite of a happens it's
because things are really good the
meaning of a and the opposite of a is
the same depending on what's convenient
at the time this guy is almost certainly
announcing next Tuesday that he's
running for president it is going to be
an insane two years it will be worse if
these people clean house tonight let's
hope we've all voted let's hope we
prevent them from doing it I have a
really interesting clip from The Joe
Rogan program Matt Walsh has become an
expert to the right wing about gender
and trans issues
he did a documentary about trans issues
he confronts people about
um gender affirming care and all these
different things and it turns out that
he's just a liar he's just a liar and
there was a very interesting moment
wherein yesterday on Joe Rogan's podcast
Matt Walsh was saying millions of trans
people are on puberty blockers hundreds
of thousands are getting hundreds of
thousands of miners prepubescent girls
are getting gender reassignment surgery
and it's all untrue let's start with the
clip it's fact checked by Joe Rogan's
producer Jamie during the the interview
and everything this is a clinic this is
a clinic in critical thinking let's
listen how many people have had this
done
depends on what I don't think we have
exact numbers but it's if we do have
exact we do have numbers we have very
good numbers on what's happening in the
United States there are there are you
can there is data for how many
procedures of just about every kind are
being done we're talking about the drugs
it's I mean Millions okay so Millions on
puberty blockers all right let's
continue
do you talk about hormone blockers yeah
but millions of kids have been on
hormone blockers really uh
I'm sure someone's going to fact check
me on me but my my guess is that we're
in we're into the millions now at this
point yeah that'll be my guess
um uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most Okay so
Millions on hormone blockers my millions
of minors on hormone blockers the best
data I was able to find is that there's
a hundred and twenty thousand
children
struggling with what is often called
gender dysphoria
some small fraction of those at some
point might take some of these
medications okay he says Millions a year
the total number with gender dysphoria
120 000 only a fraction of those are
taking these medications so first lie do
the numbers really even matter to these
people I don't think so but there's the
first lie I read a report recently that
there were over a thousand but let me
back up because now they're on to
something else uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most I read
a report recently that there were over a
thousand done between 2016 and 2019 and
when you compare that to how many were
done between you know 2008 and 2015 it's
just it's a massive okay but that's 300
a year
huh that doesn't sound so high does it
but that's not even really right let's
continue increase and uh over a thousand
girls at Double gender affirming double
mastectomies in that in that time frame
unless you're talking about prepubescent
right minors oh now did you see what
just happened there
you're talking about prepubescent
double mastectomies for prepubescent
girls we'll get back to that that
doesn't make sense either and he goes
That's Right minors okay
prepubescent and minor are two different
things
I'm sure you know that but did you see
how slickly he slipped that in I'll play
it once more
and uh over a thousand girls gender
affirming double mastectomies in that in
that time frame girls you're talking
about prepubescent right minors right
minors so two different things now of
course you might say do prepubescent
girls have breasts can you even do a
double mastectomy on a prepubescent girl
what exactly are you removing and of
course if you research this it you start
to find medical information about it it
is very rare that prepubescent girls
actually have breasts and you can read
about what happens to the nipple and
okay right I mean we don't need to go
into detail about everything but at face
value this doesn't make sense
prepubescent girls who almost never have
breasts are having their breasts removed
that's really weird but then he slips in
right these are minors so you could
actually be talking about a 17 and a
half year old girl not prepubescent
legally a minor completely different
situation doesn't make anything right or
wrong
but it's a completely different
situation than what he claims uh and
that's just up until 2019 and then we
know that uh there's been this
exponential increase with all this stuff
year over year so
um it's it's a lot it's too many you
know one having this happen to one kid
says who it's a lot more than one yeah
and look if you're an adult and you want
to do that and you understand who you
are and what you are and this is how you
feel you should progress you're an adult
this is a free country you should be
able to do whatever you want but when
you're talking about doing that to
Children the fact that so many people
are on board and so many people are
angry if you have like people are going
to be angry at us that we're having
these conversations now uh how could you
be angry that they're having the
conversation the problem is that Walsh
just lies
yeah they will be and I also
I I actually think that uh that that
this should this shouldn't be happening
to so now they've pulled up an article
that's a very small number if that's
right it says over the last five years
there were at least 4 780 adolescents
who started puberty blockers okay
he said there are millions of
adolescents on puberty blockers they
just found a study that says it's under
five thousand
over five years that's under a thousand
a year he said millions
study says it's under a thousand think
about that and at a prior gender
dysphoria diagnosis under a thousand a
year he said millions it's kind of under
counted but that's
that would be a big 100
000 people a year yeah
hmm yeah I mean I I would guess you know
hundreds of thousands
let me correct my wrong guess of
millions because you found that the real
number is 900 and say it's probably
hundreds of thousands I can't now get
away with saying it's Millions because
the data says it's 900. so let's just go
with hundreds of thousands just but I
could be wrong you are wrong million
sounds great
right it sounds it's much better for the
story
so listen guys
um there are about nine thousand the re
everything I found from medical journals
reporting on this there are about 9 000
trans surgeries performed annually
across the United States total and
that's all ages what's called male to
female and female to male that's any
type okay
that that's mostly adults okay
and
um what fraction of those are the
situation that Matt Walsh is talking
about I mean almost none now then they
always the problem with these people is
then you'll they'll they'll revert back
to even one is too many that's different
the first case they make is this is an
epidemic this is a fad everybody's doing
it you just show up and they cut off
your breasts even if you don't have any
if you're an 11 year old girl you've got
no breasts they'll cut them off what are
they cutting off Matt I don't know
they're doing it
millions of people on people you know
all this stuff then you give them the
real numbers they go well one is too
many oh but that's a different argument
now your first argument was it's too
widely available
it's absolutely horrifying and good for
Jamie for at least interjecting and
injecting some data into this okay we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here's a really good
question about our colleague Luke
Beasley who has been going to Trump
rallies recently
hey dude I actually have a question for
you and a friend of the show Luke
Beasley yep
um does he ever feel unsafe at these
rallies because
um you know you played that clip where
that guy was just cursing a lot at you
know Democrats and yeah what have these
people ever done for Americans and then
Luke named a couple things try to get a
few words in there and you know when
people are that unhinged I don't try to
talk sense into them and it's not that I
don't want Luke too I love it I love his
videos I love you know what he sends you
it's great
um I just wonder you know does he ever
feel unsafe yeah this is a fair question
and you know Luke is becoming more
recognizable because he's been going to
these rallies for a while so I I think I
I plan to have a conversation with Luke
to ask about that uh because we want the
number one priority is for Luke to be
safe and uh we we're certainly conscious
of that no doubt about it we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about Nancy Pelosi saying her
retirement will be affected by the
attack on her husband we will talk about
Facebook's plan to lay off thousands as
it is trouble in Paradise and we will
talk about Nike suspending its
relationship with Kyrie Irving over his
anti-semitic post all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad see it for yourself
don't take Alex Jones word for it sign
up at joinpathman.com